[Music]
he's all
I had to press record first what's up
fam it is Monday March 6 oh b day month
for me and Casey over here a couple
Pisces Bros and Mr Theo Von lot of
Pisces Bros going down in March St
Patty's Day
you guys do anything for St Patty's Day
Guinness
you should just be doing that for the
hell you don't need March for that
Virginia nothing I don't care about that
yeah yeah I mean I would say Patty's day
is 17th I don't know is it in our b day
is the 18th so it's like kind of
overshadows our b-day a little bit
on Friday we have some new thick boy St
Patty days merch too it's gonna be lit
be lit baby uh on the 18th you got a big
fight card
yet Leon Edwards Camaro Usman
that's going down the O2 Arena over
there across the pond you have Justin
gaichi fazive ridiculous fight
uh Gunner Nelson Brian barbarina is a
fun one but Tori Roman they did retorty
Dirty there shout out to Victoria uh
Jack sure
I always say I feel sorry who has to
fight him next coming off that loss and
my man American he's about to get it
um well how it's a [__] Savage I'm
glad he's on there on the prelims how
dare you that kid's Main Event Muhammad
that's what they call him Main Event
Muhammad by they I mean I just made that
up
um okay Russ card you know Casey O'Neill
she's a badass hell yeah Jennifer Maya
uh Herbert's a beast oh that's uh
Veronica macedo that's Dan Hardy's I
think wife or female oh that's cool uh
yeah RushCard listens not as good as
this last Saturday's card but still a
quality card we will definitely be doing
some sort of special event like a el
Capitano fight companion for that on my
b-day what a nice way to spend a a
birthday and it's in the middle
afternoons I have at night to absolutely
do nothing that would be cool
that will be cool yeah you had a big uh
fight over the weekend kids you had a
cow bass fight campaign with Will
Compton Rampage Jackson unfortunately
our boy jelly roll got caught at the
airport and uh doesn't have a license
so it's like what can you do I know what
can you do you know so it is what it is
he uh he had I think he got stuck at the
airport it didn't have TSA I think he
filmed there too he didn't film there
you know I you know Jelly's the man
he'll come back out but it was super I
listen I love jelly it would do a fun
show with jelly but man Will Compton
rampage that might be the funnest
companion I've had in a hot second
funniest companion I've had at Cal bass
Fight Club it was so much fun Will
Compton uh absolutely kills me man then
Rampage is crazy stories will just would
not get off on how much would it cost
for
Rampage of penis in his mouth I know
locker room talk you know it was so much
fun though man I had such a blast shout
out to both those boys listen to Will
Compton's podcast busting with the boys
uh it's all over but he's a he's a bar
stool dude so you can find him there the
ramp is doing the damn thing Rampage
head to Thailand I think this week to
train with Bob Sapp
for a month so we'll see how that goes
but uh yeah grand old time I never uh
you take the opportunity I never watched
those uh
I never put too much into the fights
when I'm drinking my buddies and doing
other substance you know so I always
have to watch on Sunday which I did and
uh
when I tell you about Jon Jones now
Brian count on Friday kids you know me I
think we've got two or three grand so
that's cool
but Jones called it gone into it you
don't be disrespectful with Cyril gone
but he said he's the most
one-dimensional heavyweight on the
roster and he's completely
correct saying that I don't think that's
any shade on Sarah gone but when you
look at his resume and this was the
argument
I had for every single buddy that would
argue that Jon Jones gonna be rusty or
three-year layoff it's just like yeah
but Cyril God has had an ideal run
getting to this point in his life you
know and he's never fought a Grappler so
we don't really know and then we thought
it was all smoke and mirrors when he
goes yeah I don't really train outside
of camp and people like yeah he's just
full of [__] and he says Jitsu like oh
oh he doesn't train outside of Camp you
know the the fundamentals with the the
takedowns on the cage and then as easy
as it was for Jon Jones to not only take
him down get them out and then not
protect your neck and get that
submission yeah it looked like the guy
doesn't really know what he's doing down
there at all I mean I wouldn't give him
a blue belt you know listen that doesn't
mean he's not phenomenal fighter that
doesn't mean he's not one of the best
heavyweights in the world it just means
if you have no grappling and you're
facing one of the greatest ever do it
who's really good at grappling you're
kind of [__] that's all this was
that's all I was saying it's no shade on
zero gone you know but for him that
that's a tough tough matchup and you can
see his face he's like oh my God Jesus
Christ you know so
I I would sum up UFC 285 like this
there's a lot of questions that need to
be answered that didn't get answered
overall from for for the main card
especially so we'll kick it off with
this with bow nickel uh Jamie Pickett
you know
bow every single outing he's had has
been a Flawless home run Victory and
there's literally nothing you can say
besides the competition he's facing but
remember he only has three fights so he
should be facing those guys but he is
mopping the floor with every single
person he's in there with for this fight
Jamie Pickett you know he is coming off
a two fight losing skid So Jamie
Pickett's a good first fight for a guy
of Beau Nichols caliber with his
experience especially in the UFC on the
big stages first UFC fight he's on the
main card rightfully so definitely don't
put that kid on the prelude for God's
sakes but you know even though he didn't
get touched
people say oh he hit the guy in the nuts
I'm not even bothered by that that
doesn't matter the kid would have been
choked out what maybe 30 seconds faster
everything kick him in the nuts you know
that's just [__] happens it's also not
the end of the world so get over it but
it looked like Bo was kind of forcing
the submission there and this is how
good bow is you're trying to critique
him and he didn't get hit once in the
fight so there's still some questions we
answered there
um for Bo nickel they nothing changes
for him nothing changes for him they
still have to have him on this
aggressive path to get to a contender so
I don't think they're gonna give him
another guy of Jamie Pickett's caliber
they're going to give him his next
fight's gonna be a guy on a winning
streak I would assume because you know
Bo Nicko at this point there are there
have been no chinks in his armor
um besides a gas forcing that had arm
choke you know
um could have stepped off to side
control you know there's not a lot to
hate on the guy for so
they do need to keep him on the current
path they have them on but he would need
to fight a guy not ranked
you know but I do think you beat ranked
guys but not yet you know it's a it's a
marathon not a Sprint so I think they
give them knacks a guy who's maybe on a
two fight winning streak maybe three
fight win streak definitely has to be
coming off at least one win so then
that's the next step and then you know
he's two or three fights away from being
right in those the top top dogs there so
he's gonna be a tough uh a tough outing
for anybody anybody in the top 15. but
real quick on that too so I guess Jamie
Pickett's team is gonna actually try to
do an appeal which we all know never
really works right yeah it's literally
just a waste time oh that's why you
think you lost yeah it wasn't because
you got taken down it wasn't because
you're shitty you know a head armed
defense you know now that's you don't
you don't take any accountability you
think the only reason he got taken down
and choked us because he got hit in the
nuts come on dude take accountability
[__] up you gotta take him down you're
getting down no matter what you're also
coming off a two fights losing skid this
is three now you know so just just take
it and Bo said he hit the leg not the
groin so yeah both said yeah but even if
he kind of touched in that second okay
okay that's a good point yeah oh where
are you gonna get submitted yeah were
you not did you get hit in the nuts I'm
like oh my God my takedown offense is so
good can you hit me in the nuts he'd
never take me down
never how dare you uh game right had a
good win Jalen turn is no punks with
decision two
um I saw people call him for a gamerat
deserves the winner of gaichi for fazive
I maybe I mean he's what he's won one
out of his last two you know he did lose
to Darius but before that he was on a
streak so I don't know if he's there
yeah I would assume the winner of
especially if physiv wins he gets a Top
Shot so he's not going to fight for
zeeve I could see if Justin Gates you
him but the caliber just engages that I
don't think gamrat's there yet
especially look at his build up uh in
order to get
to Jalen Turner you know he had a what a
one two three four fight uh win streak
but it wasn't you know Scott Holtzman uh
Jeremy Stevens Carlos Vieira uh that
that was a good one yeah is a great win
and then he lost it Darius
be tough to toss him in there with a big
name like gaichi right now and the
physiv wins because he's definitely not
getting physique physique fine fight
title if he wins you know that's where
fazeb's at but yeah you look phenomenal
but Jalen turns a tough outing for him
let's take a little break from chatting
all about UFC 285 the goat is back
Oklahoma City breaks down Comedy Club
this Thursday Friday Saturday March 9th
through the 11th it's going down in
Oklahoma City bricks down Comedy Club
get you some the Nakoma Washington is
March 23rd through the 25th get your
tickets right now at thickboy.com or
fatkz.com Oklahoma City I'll see you
this freaking weekend one thing I'll
tell you about Oklahoma City when you
see me on stage your boy will be on that
Kratom that's right it's the only
product I take to get myself ready to go
it's my Limitless pill and I only
recommend this product because I
actually use it every single day it's
Kratom from Happy Hippo happyhippo.com I
use it every single day it's the only
Kratom that I trust to get stuff done it
keeps me in a good mood it keeps me well
balanced I feel great I use this shot
right here
I have in the case right here usually I
drink all of them so they're never
around me but this is the Kratom shot
this is the highly concentrated happy
hippo sour apple they have butterscotch
which I love
um so get you some man it's the Hidden
Gem Kratom is on locks your Limitless
your brain Limitless it's nothing better
happyhippo.com promo code is thick23
that's t h i c c 23 for the best Kratom
on planet Earth you can try in pill form
gummy form the shots that I take they
got powder they got it all so everyone
get your Kratom get it from Happy Hippo
it's happy hippo.com promo code is
thick23 you can share that use as many
times you want for life right that's
happyhippo.com promo code thick23 this
episode of UFC
285 of the shop show is brought to you
by the one the only
on it on its supplements Nutrition
Fitness apparel they got it all if
you've never heard of on it you're
living under a rock it's the only
supplement I can trust you'll see a lot
of guys in the NFL get busted UFC get
busted for tainted supplements if
they're using audit you wouldn't have to
worry about any of that stuff because
their company can freaking rely on and
Trust what they say is in the bottle is
actually in the bottle no funny games
are being played when you use audit
supplements whether it's the new mood
total gut health they got freaking
shrimp Tech they got protein powders
creatine they got all sorts of Keto
things and then their Alpha Brain the
number one nootropic on the planet
they've sold over a million bottles of
the regular Alpha Brain if you've never
tried a nootropic start with Alpha Brain
but if you're crazy like me and need a
little extra in the tank get that Alpha
Brain Black Label it's the highly
concentrated for the real do-gooders out
there if you're trying to get things
done Alpha Brain Black Label I can't
recommend enough they have Alpha Brain
instant you just put it in eight ounces
the water and it's instantly ready to go
the Alpha Brain Focus shot is going to
get you speaking like Jeff Bezos you
start making business plans with your
buddies you never even thought were
possible that's Alpha Brain Black Label
and save temps off the Black Label
regular Alpha Brain instant Alpha Brain
Alpha Brain Focus shot all the protein
powder streaming Fitness apparel Fitness
Gear from their on-demand workouts to
their streaming home fitness programs
yoga mats sandbags steel Club Macy's
quad maces kettlebells Primal Bells
audit.com job you save 10 off all the
best nootropics on the planet including
Alpha Brain Black Label Focus shot
instant Alpha Brain regular Alpha Brain
protein powders streaming Fitness you
save ten percent off everything I just
told you about go to audit.com
schab Safe 10 off now let's get back to
the program
uh and then again there's no question
marks on gamrat he's the only one that I
think have the main card I don't have
any questions about
Echo we have some questions just
you didn't learn much about him yet
especially if you're not familiar with
bonega because this was like his first
intro to the masses especially the
casuals like they're like pretty good
but even though he dominated and beat
the guy in two minutes and 54 seconds
it should have been even easier than
that so there's still some people
especially if you're new to them you
don't find out a lot about Bo nickel yet
you didn't find out a ton so there's
some question with Bo not for me I'd say
for the audience uh with uh Chef cat
again I I there are some questions here
was that a catch weight against uh Jeff
Neal right
um this wasn't an easy outing for
shotcon in any facet so a lot of people
will say
went by a lot of people in chevron's
team they go we thought we needed one or
two warm-ups to get to title shot but
we're ready to go right now God
completely disagree I completely
disagree I think uh Jeff Neal came in
with a great game plan
um he did hurt cotton some you know some
incidents there had some success in
certain areas this wasn't like a
landslide he was in a [__] fight man
you know and now he did what Chevron
does and gets the finish and got it done
by any means necessary and he's a
complete Savage he proved that but
there's some question marks there where
you're just like all right Jeff Neal is
ranked number seven now do we think
shopkat should go from number seven up
to he's talking about title shot that's
not happening that's just unrealistic
especially at 170 that division stacked
but even for shopkat to beat Jeff Neal
was it that impressive where he should
get a Colby Covington was it that
impressive we should be to [__]
believe Mohammed
I don't think so
you know now if he's feeling super
froggy if he's feeling Z frog a I got a
guy who's looking for a fight to
spitballing ideas here and he's not he's
not a title holder but oh he'll be your
Huckleberry it's from he's from chechnya
we call him that Daddy that Daddy harms
odd now that's if harms out wants to
find at 70. I think his days are playing
at 70 are over I think even the UFC's a
little skeptical on it you know so I
think his days are at 85 and eventually
205 I think 70's done for him but who
knows who knows what his team's thinking
but I think it's too tough of a cut but
uh
gun to the Head chin maybe not a gun
like a plastic gun not like a real gun
who do you think's gonna win who'd
[__] tell me suck your dick tell me
who's going to suck my dick
Will Compton stuff man y'all wait why is
there gonna be a gun to my head dude
um who would you take over shop caught
at nine versus homs at it at
welterweight homicide yeah who would you
take over uh shopkop versus Colby
Covington that's a good one I don't know
I I would lean towards Colby but I do
yeah but I think it's more 50 50. you
know and you know why this back to my
whole point of this entire UFC 285 card
you need some questions answered there's
there's some questions about shopkat
where 17-0 [__] you know all finishes
Savage yeah but it wasn't that he didn't
dominate the number seven guy in the
world that's deserving to say right now
like you're telling me he smokes Wonder
Boy Thompson that's a good fight for him
you think he beats Wonder Boy
I'm not confident he he might be a
slight favorite in that but wonderboy's
been doing the damn thing you tell me uh
shotgun beats Gilbert Burns no
tough fight for him Muhammad
I don't I'll take Muhammad over here me
too don't get me started I think he
beats everybody in the planet and then
Kobe Compton's tough one Camaro and Leon
Edwards
phenomenal talent I do think eventually
using me champ but I think it's insane
for him to go from he was ranked what
number 10 and now he's ranked with did
they change the ratings already uh
tomorrow so so he'll probably jump up
he'll be seven
there's no way you're gonna put him over
Wonderboy so he'll be seven it'd be
tough look at that lineup so Wonder boys
doing the damn thing Gilbert Burns has a
huge fight against Mazda doll Muhammad
is more deserving than anybody that
we've mentioned on here uh Hamza is just
looming in the [__] Shadows waiting
to eat somebody's dick off Kobe
Covington's do they're saying they're
trying him fights it's not working out
Karma Kamara Usman Leon Edwards so once
March 18th passes by there's gonna be a
little more clarity but you cannot tell
me and this is no shade on shopkat he's
such a Savage there's so much potential
there he has all the writings on the
wall to be your future champ I'm just
saying I have some questions right now
against Jeff Neal I it wasn't that easy
of an outing and that's Jeff Neal's a
beast he's number seven for a [__]
reason Bob is saying after once you dip
your toe in those top five
top six to show me the fight he he'd be
favored in maybe wonderboy's favorite
that's a tough go outing for him Gilbert
Burns probably not favored Muhammad not
favored Hamza get on my [__] face
Cody Covington not favorite Chronicles
but not favored maybe Leon Edwards he
would be favorite because of the ground
I don't know yeah yeah so all I'm saying
I got some questions that's it
no Shayla I'm a huge fan such a Savage
he finds a way to work when yep
uh and then again uh more questions so
you got Alexa Grosso Valentina
chefchenko it's just a matter of time
before chefchenko got caught I mean her
last fight it was you know there's a
little dicey people thought she lost she
ended up winning and then Alexa Grosso
comes up and Alexa in that first round
was doing really well probably thought
she lost the second round and valtina
started to find success with her
takedowns over Alexa and then she throws
that spinning back kick gives up her
back and Alexa jumped on her like a
goddamn Mexican koala bear and they
planned for that too did they they did
yeah amazing amazing so now Mexico has
two world champions I'm sure people
online like we have three interim
doesn't count
I'm talking about two legit no
controversy no debate two legit Mexican
Champions now fire Beats
the pound for pound goat folk
volkanovsky then he's your official
champ then Maxfield has three but right
now you have two and a half
all right you have two and a half but
shout out to Alexa Grosso now
I got some questions
so Alexa Grosso wins
the UFC's known for giving Champions
immediate rematches I don't really want
to see the rematch those don't do much
for me
um but I would assume chefchenko's
favorite in that fight you know and if
you're the UFC if for whatever reason
you don't give chefchenko who's you know
the greatest flyweight to ever do it if
you don't give her immediate rematch
there's some other girls can get it done
you know some of the girls vying for you
know their chance at a title shot
you gotta you gotta I mean Aaron
blanchfield right there for sure yeah
she probably has the most hype around
her it's a weird division though right
because blanchfield did her damn thing
she's three
if your funeral is number one uh Santos
lost super controversial decision
um Jessica and Josh yep she lost Julian
Yips and then Alexa grass was number six
and she's your world champion
so once I would assume once chefchenko
leaves that division that belt's gonna
get passed around like a
like a like a like a like a pun or like
like a punter and will Compton's locker
room
you know it's just a it's just a weird
division I'm not too keen on the rematch
it you know it's tough I think you let
Alexa grass to do her thing I think you
have uh bran Moreno I think you have her
Alexia Grasso and you have yay Rodriguez
and you just stacked that car to Mexico
City man that'd be sick yeah if you're
gonna do the rematch I still want to see
if chefchenko Nunez
can't really do it now but she's not the
champ yeah right now she'd have to win
one and then do it even though it'd be a
different weight class but yeah and Dana
was like there's no reason to do it
especially since she lost but if she got
one then maybe her last fight I don't
know how much she has left in the tank
either she's what 35 sochenko yeah
let's take a real quick look she's 34 34
yeah 34 birthday March 7th
coming up couple Pisces doing the damn
thing
yeah I mean she has a great [__] run
man what seven time world champion
defending you know she's doing the damn
thing she wants the rematch and then
Alexa says she deserves it because she's
been you know that's a tough fight for
Alexa but who knows maybe she has the
confidence down she can beat her but
that fight was headed towards
chefchenka's way until she did that spin
back kick like Luke rockhold exactly so
yeah uh again back to more questions Jon
Jones right Flawless Victory didn't get
touched by Cyril gone
submit him in within two minutes like
your boy call not a big deal made a lot
of money off of it but
I have some questions because before the
takedown before all that stuff did you
think Jon Jones stand up looked good did
you think he looked quick on the feet
he looks a little rusty right
I mean because I don't know if it's just
it's hard to tell just look he just
looks slower because he's so like you
know yeah he has his belly on him but
you have some questions right like I
have some questions that's the point of
the show I got some questions on John
and I'm the biggest Jon Jones dick rider
man I you know he I think he's the
panther goat no question now being
heavyweight champ going up to
heavyweight defeating Cyril gone no
question but
um yeah I get some questions because
it's tough because also in the
heavyweight division
Cyril gone can wrestle I'm not sure God
uh curse Blaze can wrestle his ass off
so that could be an issue for him he's
forced to stand we I just have some
questions as far as John if he doesn't
get the takedown what's it look like not
saying he can't just get some questions
he's still the goat but I do got some
questions we didn't learn anything that
night we learned that he can still
wrestle I think Sarah God is not you
know is no background no jiu jitsu so
yeah John like phenomenal easiest fight
of his career hands down easiest fight
he's ever had a guy that has literally
zero wrestling doesn't trade in the
offseason easiest fight of his career
uh I do think steepe is going to be more
of a threat and remember Steve it can
wrestle Cleveland State uh guy wrestling
in college so you know but he's getting
steep a compromise right it's an older
Steve Bay but I think we'll find out a
little more about where Jon Jones at it
is that is at a heavyweight because also
for John three year layoff this and
there's no warm-up fights in the UFC but
this was a warm-up fight for him even
though it was for a world title this a
guy who can't wrestle in any capacity
this was a warm-up fight so the steebe
fight I think we're gonna find out a lot
more about where Jon Jones is at a
heavyweight than we did in the zero God
fight that's clear as day get him down
submit them that's what he did Steve
basically tougher to take down will he
take down probably yeah I'd be willing
to bet John can take down Steve took
down DC for God's sakes so I would
assume he gets Stipe down we're gonna
find a lot more about Jon Jones in those
three years and what he's been working
on in his next two fights opposed to the
surrogon fight he's a fighter Square
again I got some questions that's all
I'm saying
um
yeah I guess when you look at the
division too Stipe makes the most sense
you know you look at the heavyweight
division step a
he deserves it he's right there it's
also a huge feather in John's cap John
was talking about though you know he
said he I have at least two fights left
yeah at least so that means he's kind of
quite like he's not saying how I'm here
to you know Reign for like I did at the
light heavyweight he's just saying like
at least two more so it'd be the what
the steepe fight and then probably the
winner of Sergey uh pavlovic and Curtis
blades
Sergey probably a surrogon Steve
siragon stibbe aren't his toughest
matchups it just so happens his toughest
matchups aren't the straight up
contenders right now Curtis blades and
Sergey are would be his toughest
matchups and then I honestly think the
toughest matchup out of anybody in the
world is a man named Tom aspinall that
would be by far Jones toughest matchup
black belt on the ground good stand up
great movement quick on his feet Natural
Born heavyweight that could be a problem
for him if his knee was better so I'm
hoping Tom comes back what maybe end of
this year so I would assume John fights
Stipe in July in the big UFC card that
they do in the summer probably close the
year out against Sergey Curtis Blade's
winner and then hopefully by 2024 early
get Tom aspinall after that I would
assume John's done
of course Francis fights there if he
comes back like he's never allowed so
you saw that yeah if you like Deontay
Wilder you're gonna be jacking that big
old winner you ain't fooling nobody Doug
yeah all I'm saying is he has some
questions but I do think the biggest
threat to Jon Jones heavyweight Reign is
Tom aspinel if his leg gets healthy
good card overall though man yeah fun
night that companions available right
now if you haven't watched it it was so
much fun man
uh Cody garbrat yeah we didn't talk
about the prelims Cody garbrand our boy
got it done my god did he need that yeah
thank the Lord thank the lord lord Cody
garban I got it done uh do policies I
thought that was gonna be a tough
tougher fight for him
uh cardio still an issue I feel like
with him always breathing hard always
looks like he's breathing as hard as
possible
um and then Ian Gary uh phenomenal fight
his comma to finish uh song Kina Keenan
off was ridiculous ridiculous Ian Gary
has Superstar written all over I think
that's four in a row can't help but love
the kid he was great
yeah overall good night of fights kids
what else catching let's just double
check yeah 400 right yeah four in a row
uh I know this is a stupid question I'm
gonna say this right away but DC is
there any possibility that DC would want
to come back because Jon Jones is a
heavyweight no he's good to go right
yeah good he's good to go yeah good to
go
I figured
uh you mentioned Cordy garbach he said
something about the day of the fight
like in the morning he was warming up
and he did something where I guess he
landed somewhere and his neck got jacked
up and he couldn't even his arm wouldn't
function one of his arms would function
so he probably messed up his necks all
the yeah yeah and he had issues before
with that stuff so but luckily he was
able to you know get the Finish or get
the job done
sometimes an injury like that forced you
to be more focused you know where you
might have other things or other
thoughts going on your head but that
injury forces you to [__] download it
in so it could have been good for him
get out of his way
shoot up uh so this is what Francis
Agana put as soon as John Bones Jones
won good job Johnny Boy sincerely the
heavyweight King and then
so uh let me just tell you the video
because this is better so I'll just play
this video it's it's through the press
conference so I think we're fine
boy sincerely the heavyweight King do
you have response to Francis and ganu
preparing himself Francis is a big old
[__]
[Applause]
as simple as that he's a big let's just
type in the fight but they're smart they
should be doing this and enforce This
Dana to negotiate with friends oh dude
that's what we need yeah
but yeah you're telling me John doesn't
beat Francis come on man
France to grab one ain't great either
that's the thing it's just John
heavyweight he's a nightmare for these
guys they can't [__] wrestle man
Curtis blades can so you know the only
time Curtis is lost when he gets caught
coming in blasting for a double but
striking's getting better so he's giving
me a handful but the rest of these guys
have zero grappling zero wrestling
John can wrestle his ass off it's like
for France it's like the only thing
you're been on is he lands one big
Haymaker yeah but if that a maker
doesn't land he's doing exactly to
Francis what he did to Cyril gone
exactly the same way
so you know heavyweights and how they
move when you said you saw John before
when he was a light heavy versus heavy
we didn't see enough obviously it was so
fast yeah he did look he did look heavy
plotting so he did it's tough to tell
but I think even I saw a post-fight
thing with John and he was like yeah I
felt a little rusty up with just in the
stand up I felt uncomfortable so that's
just he's gonna get those rounds in with
steep base t-based on give me a quick
finish but he looks so freaking
confident in this just his first heavy
like debut he looks so confident I'm
like yeah if his speeds there yeah
because he's fighting a white belt I was
like I'm just gonna take this schmuck
down watch this yeah that was so fast uh
so we uh I don't know if we talked about
this but there until there's news that
he was released from the UFC it was kind
of up in the air we're not sure what
happened but according to there until I
think he spoke with Brett okamoto and he
said that uh he asked to be released
from the UFC and they were cool with
them and they released them because he
has issues with his knees like really
bad he wants to get some shots done and
he might use
exactly I am I don't mind that I mean
you know how long is he gonna be out he
said two to three years which is a long
time
yeah that's probably the end of the road
for him right it's two three years at
his level and you're coming off how many
losing five out of six yeah lost five
out of six tough to tough to make
comeback so apparently he's cool with
the the guys though like Hunter Campbell
and the team so they're they like him a
lot I'm sure but it's like three years I
know who knows it three years yeah and
how old is he he's been fighting forever
too it didn't seem like he's out just a
bomber man it's just such a the whole
thing bums me out about him
he goes I've been suffering for the past
two years it's no secret I think now at
this point I also I've been speaking to
Hunter ever since my Robert Whittaker
fight where I injured my knee he's going
he's been going crazy at me for like two
years he's like till I can't take much
more of this he's like I've got your
back I know you're going to be a champ
stuff like that he says to me but he's
like you need to get your knees right he
said this before my last fight he said
before the fight before that
I yeah I do yeah clearly these are an
issue for Darren Taylor and then
obviously his mental games also an issue
he's only 30.
man be nothing better if he does have a
comeback I would love that for him
that'd be great you hope you hope he can
get his [__] together three years M.I.A
be tough and then to jump into the pool
in the heavy I'm sorry in the welterway
division Walter wealth right or
middleweight be tough and he did say
since he was released that you know
obviously a lot of people are hitting
him up but he's not going to be able to
do anything anyways other than
potentially like a boxing type of match
because it's not you know
not wrestling or anything that to mess
up his knees so he said he's had some
crazy offers I'm sure bear knuckle um
some other leagues but if
if it's actually your knees you should
have focus on getting better why would
you risk no so that's why he's like yeah
I'm not
he doesn't plan to do it but he's a
two-year plan in my mind I feel like
it's going to be [__] unbelievable
plan I'm going to execute it to the most
I can that's it I don't want to say too
much about it but I'm going to make a
truckload of money I'm gonna probably do
a striking match or two because that's
my fourth day and hopefully by then I'll
figure this rupture with my knee and
stuff and I'll be good to go this is how
many guys go to the UCC release me how
many guys actually do that some of the
guys when they're on their way out like
Nate Diaz want to be released stuff like
that but there's not many guys who do
that and I've had a lot of time to think
about my decision that's why I was happy
with Hunter
said uh big decision
give me two weeks to think yeah I hope I
listen I wish her the best hopefully it
works out yeah
I think I think he he needs to work on
his knees and his mental game you know
that's what it is with him he's so
talented definitely definitely
um so bkfc
I'm not sure if we talked about this yet
but Luke rockhold is fighting Mike Perry
Yeah Eddie Alvarez versus Chad Mendes
oh this thing's all jacked up that Jamba
Juice Jamba Juice dog accidentally
clicked on it add it's weird it's Mike
Perry uh fighting Luke rockhold a
picture of Eddie Alvarez yeah
but then that's so far this is the
lineup that I've seen Mike Perry
Luke rockhold Mendez and Alvarez is
awesome as well and then also Beck
Rawlings she's coming back and fighting
a girl named for hair yeah that's great
yeah yeah bare knuckle doing the damn
thing that thing Colorado these are good
signings right yeah the Mike Perry
rockled one so interesting to me because
it's like you'd think Rock cold would
just mop the floor with him but Mike
Perry's a dog and Mike Perry owns bare
knuckle look you know rock old technique
wise and accomplishment yeah it has more
than uh Mike Perry in MMA but when it
comes to Bare knuckle it's just what
Mike Perry is born to do man and he's
looking at his fight with Michael Van
impeach by any
expert's opinion by any regard he should
have got [__] up in that fight did he
[__] Michael and pay he's just a nasty I
know he's a street fighter yeah so it's
like you know Luke's a pretty boy and he
can enter those dark Waters but Mike
Perry he was born in the dark waters you
know what I'm saying like you're dealing
with just a straight dog so that's why
it's interesting you know yeah
of course Mendez and Eddie Alvarez
interesting as [__] too for sure
and I think all of them are
I mean the testing's not gonna be that
crazy they're mentally cool yeah cool
dog be cool man we gotta go there man
I'm just saying don't steal sunshine
away no that's even better I think yeah
oh yeah
um yeah but who knows
um
let's bypass this right here
well let me just talk about real quick
I'll make it super simple fast so uh
I guess John Fury obviously Tommy fear
is dead uh Jake Paul said something
about I bet you my purse that I'll win
this and that whatever
and then after obviously Jake Paul lost
top um John fear was like we we made
that bet we should have like you should
honor that bet right and then there was
footage later on I think someone you
could see Logan Paul there or whatever
how they're talking like what's up with
the contract of the actual bet and then
John first like let's talk about the
fight let's talk about the fight oh
they're saying that he never wanted to
sign that contract because Jake was like
I'm down but we need the proper paper
yes I'm about to take you on your word
and then he never signed it now John
Fury is like hey we made that bet he's
like nah [__] we try to get you to sign
we were down to do it exactly
interesting and I think yeah this is uh
from Mike Michael Benson this is from
Jake Paul's manager responds to John
Fury calling to pay up after this Dear
John congratulations on the win I've
grown to highly respect you off camera
however the statement shocked again what
you said to me at this At His Highness
house on Friday evening in the
correspondence from your your Tommy's
lawyer moreover our team has you on
camera refusing to agree to the deal out
of the fight with all that said fair
play to Tommy on a Gear Performance he
meant great uh you have raised a great
young man hopefully he has the courage
to do it again best
interesting yeah yeah
you probably don't realize how like you
know these young kids have everything on
video and [__] it's like we made the bet
you're like nah [__] yeah and who's
gonna I don't think that's even legal so
I don't know no yeah uh this is just
early estimates not there's no like
sufficient substantial evidence is real
but this is from uh so this is from Jake
this is from David Meltzer oh good but
they don't know even he doesn't know the
exact pay-per-view box but this is for
Jake Paul versus Tommy Fury yes because
the show is on ESPN plus we don't know
the exact buys the rumor number from
social no was 200 000 which would be
more than Paul did for his fights with
him Silva and the second
Woodley fight
um
Paul himself claimed it was tracking
about five hundred thousand so we don't
know we don't know and then this I saw
from KSI responding to this is pretty
much Jake Paul's team saying that their
pay-per-view buys were at least let's
see like 775 000 it says confirmed from
MVP updates
and then KSI just said you still lost
I don't know who's building that fight
so if item KSI let me know how it goes
for you that so now I never would have
cared about that before but now I'm like
[__] who the [__] I mean I still take
Jake on that but I'll take Jake yeah
yeah
and 775 000 would be nuts I know if
that's real
and I heard the UFC the UFC 285 was the
most trending UFC fight since Conor and
Eddie Alvarez I think
it's like the number one most trending
most talked about fight online so it
should do really good buys but now with
freaking all this stream the streaming
and stealing stuff yeah yeah like I
heard some uh guys in the green were
like I was like oh you're gonna get the
fights like oh we never buy a man people
stream them on Tick Tock yeah they can
do Tick Tock he's like Tick Tock or
SnapChat just leave the video up and
then they get what flags in this
commercials they just pull it down
during the commercials you're like oh
damn
I know that's there has to be a way to
figure that out but I don't know what
that is Logan Paul wants to avenge Jake
Paul's last time for you I'd like to
handle that it's just a quick one it'll
be a tough fight for Logan yeah I mean
Tommy's way better boxing but Logan is
huge if I'm talking like hell yeah let's
do it
for sure but that's it that like I told
you before when I break down that fight
they need to stay in their Lane with
that stuff fight Logan fight Jake yeah
Connor do all that stuff KSI don't step
over the real boys yep
this is Jon Jones this is Jon Jones
message to Stephen because you know
Stipe does I think he does part-time
firefighter so he was I would take time
out from being a firefighter right now
and I mean that with all due respect my
whole world is going to be focused on
him so the biggest opportunity in my
life to beat the heavyweight goat I'm
going to give it everything I got
absolutely everything I got I'm going to
not only beat Steven I'm going to finish
steepe before the championship rounds
the whole prediction that's fair to stay
yeah I don't think that's like an
extreme
um I'm gonna go back to Jon Jones in a
bit but this is Tony Ferguson this is
pretty bold he made a tweet about Dana
White and then he deleted it but I'll
show you the actual thing that he said
here
uh he said it's gonna take a class
action lawsuit to let some of these
so-called Untouchables get a taste of
their own medicine Mac yeah who's back
if this [__] treated his lady in
public like that how do you think he
treats his Fighters underneath he's
talking about Dana White slapping his
wife yes yeah interesting
but then he deleted it
and he's still with UFC as far as I know
so well remember they're going to do
Tony verse yeah Connor and then they
decided he said different way he brought
that up too like you know they're
treating Chandler way better than him
and this and that whatever
yeah he gets messy yeah
definitely messy and this is do you
remember when Dana White did this uh
like mini documentary when the whole
cover thing happened afterwards because
oh yeah he said he was because the way
the media was yeah they're saying making
like a bad guy and it's not so he's
planning on doing another one with why
people are talking smack on the UFC
power slap and he's gonna like you know
whatever I know man you have to be it'll
be cool man be cool
I don't need that dog please dude I'm
saying it's entertaining I just think
it's [__] dude you're probably the
best one the supporter of it I mean not
supportive but you're you gave it a
chance like you're like yeah like I'm
watching it so [__] ridiculous but I
don't see how it's even allowed him dude
I'm 23. yeah and he was talking to
Robbie Foxx your dude and he just hates
me like the one like I'm sure he's gonna
have in there what they did to Rogan and
him and all this [__] power slap Fight
League he just won't give it up that's a
bad idea I get it dude I fight dude I
get it Dana I'm with you bro Double Down
dog doubled down he's like this would be
the next big thing kids even grow up
slapping each other because of me it's
like hey let it go it's not happening
yeah uh but if you want to watch the
whole interview it's on Robbie Foxx a
good one
uh just let it go it's so funny all
those time and resources hasn't worked
out people were crushing on Tick Tock
you're like [__]
until I know you're losing you got to do
it though I mean oh I dude I you gotta
Double Down
uh actually this one don't worry about
this one let's go to
um
um it's not bodybuilding competition oh
that's awesome he goes I'm 250 pounds
still moving like a light heavyweight no
because he got so much like so many
people went after him after they
actually finally saw him without a shirt
on and posing yeah because even he was
thick yeah we're used to be shredded
yeah but also remember at 205 that was a
big cut for him so he's he's depleting
his body of all the nutrients so he's so
dehydrated he's a big ass 205er yeah so
you're seeing him in Prime like no body
fat so you go from that to thick thick
you know and then the short shorts ain't
helping anybody the muffin top hang over
the top it's like the shorts are I don't
know you can't go along with shorts I'm
with him you got to Double Down dude do
what Dana does the slap Fight League
Double Down dude
but he said he's going to be like I
think I look dope he's gonna start
working on leaning out now that he's
just this is his first fight at
heavyweight so yeah he's gonna focus on
leaning out
uh all right
I know it was a lot that sucks dude
they're factually with John he's like I
felt good [__] man he's like I'll
tightened up
baddest man on the planet you know you
fat piece of [__] he's like I know I
feel it I'm gonna tighten up for this
next one the internet's fat shame Jon
Jones is a losing weight at heavyweight
I get it dude
yeah
uh okay
[Music]
this is actually good news so the judge
in the whole cave in Velasquez and that
guy that case that Molly station case
yeah the guy that was accused molesting
will have to take stand in the trial now
which is great people first Kane's team
I think I can't believe the homies that
haven't gone to that guy I mean
yeah
piece of [__]
definitely and then I'm sure you saw all
this stuff building up I didn't know
this I don't think they even promoted
this but Conor McGregor and Jake
Gyllenhaal showed up at the press
conference no I saw it you did did you
see his weigh-in boys first team all
done dude he's Jack Jack City yeah but
even Dana goes I don't think you saw
this testing him yeah you look great
yeah I don't know if I can play this
clip but were you were you guys watching
the prelims like there was this long
like Ronda Rousey like promo and you're
like why why is this taking on so long
because Jake and uh
Jay Heron was filming for the movie and
they didn't want you to see that but the
you know on online the crowd's like what
the [__] going on they're filming it
ah it shows him like it shows Jake
Gyllenhaal getting against cage gets hit
then he gets then he hits uh Jay Huron
and he throws us a jumping knee yeah
yeah there it is I mean I'm not sure we
could show this so anyways there's you
can go on any like website there's
you'll see Jake gyllenha and Jay here on
fake fighting so and so they should have
cast Steve masgotti fight would still be
going on
that's cool that they have Jay here I
mean Jay huron's doing all these movies
now because he was you know using UFC
for a while but then he's the band yeah
he's been doing movies for a while
all right anyways
oh this is
as soon as Jon Jones is gonna fight Mark
hunt made this little statement I saw
this he was hard in the paint really so
this is my cut not my words sick of this
rat company on my feet all they do is
promote steroids using wrath like this
loser referring to Jon Jones uh listen
up it's the world heavyweight title of
the worthless rubbish belt worth nothing
you got a steroid using rodent who runs
over pregnant women and hides under the
Octagon when usada is trying to drug
test this rodent UFC equals joke belt
the only thing you are a world champion
of is being explode exploited that's why
the UFC will never be credible because
they have rodents like this being
considered the goat hashtag Ally act and
dasiate
that's it
yeah so he's still definitely
yeah not happy
here's another quick one remember David
Branch he was actually yeah wsof
Champion
yeah black belt badass on the ground so
he decided to officially retire good for
him great guy
cool
and those were his last fights 2019 but
he was killing it before man yeah he was
real helpful back in the day yeah
um oh I thought this was powerful
um
this is I don't know when this is when
Anthony Johnson fought uh Daniel Cormier
right
I'll just play this for you real quick
and uh my man bones right
[Music]
maybe in the next life go do that
if maybe the next life he said like
be crazy
so that just started popping up yeah
yeah
uh all right here's a more fun one Lara
senko obviously she's super Dime Piece
right super dimes and then I guess uh
during the broadcast for at the pre-show
Daniel Cormier was complimenting her for
wearing the shopkat Ramada of hat thing
I'll just wait real quick this is
awkward or what hold on yeah not too
awkward you look beautiful with that hat
thank you like stunning yeah you guessed
you've gotten too far you gotta chill
she looks pretty huh yeah but you gotta
stop yeah but she's my sister she's like
my little sister yeah I can say right
yeah you're calling your little sister
hot I mean Laura you look beautiful
hey you gotta stop hey hey pump the
brakes
DC is like you I'm rock hard right now
no she's like my little sister white was
like
yeah that's just some bro talk she she
did look uncomfortable there and she's
all okay shout to learn thank God love
her uh this one is just a quick one this
is not from this weekend it was like
last week or something Javonte Davis
rolled up in this badass truck
uh I don't know what that is what is
like a big ass it's Converse
GMC or some [__]
I mean if he's still living in where he
lives Brian needs that thing
god that car is ridiculous big truck for
a little dude
it's like a legit tank well if you just
rolled in the tank that'd be sick not me
that's sick
um let's go oh this happened at UFC 285
in a parking lot someone just ran up to
Ian Gary smart trying to fight him yeah
anger's in a tuxedo who's all his old
lady with Ian Grandma Jesus Christ man
what's wrong with this guy
you're welcome
so the guy's like I prom I do this too I
promise you the inside I do this too oh
yeah yeah where at
yeah anyways Ian you know de-escalated
this oh yeah did you do it on UFC 285
you [__] [__]
uh oh yeah I think this might be the
last one we'll see but you remember we
showed that uh Jon Jones is gonna have
an after party
I wish I was there so everyone was
worried that he's gonna go crazy and
stuff that he did go to it he did dance
and all that stuff no I bet he did and
before that Dana White wanted to get him
a charter jet like a private jet just to
go home after the fight just to make
sure he's safe yeah nothing happened and
I was like he had nothing to worry about
baby be cool man and then he goes no
Danny White knows that we all make
mistakes he said that
he said come on that'll be cool we all
make mistakes right yep and he goes I'm
different now and then so I remember
Johnny oh Johnny uh Jon Jones put like a
either like an Instagram story out of
something about him in the hotel room
after the party with his coach like you
know done taking you know he seemed
lucid dream of everything hey back in
the hotel room which is awesome though
yeah I mean you got to go to certain
places to learn your lesson some guys
learn more difficult than the other and
then his his wife being there says a lot
yeah well I remember him hearing him on
a an interview with uh Michael Bisby and
BT Sport and then he mentioned wife and
I'm like wife I thought they broke up or
whatever but apparently they're back
together everything's wrong the
internet's undefeated I saw a meme it
shows John walking off like this and
Cyril's gone face like this this is when
you realize John's wife lasted longer
than you did
so what the [__] holy [__] dude people
are Savage Oh my dude people are [__]
rude I don't get it man I know these
young Millennials do there's just no
line is too much that reminds me there's
a freaking meme I don't know okay this
one I just saw this I wasn't gonna play
show it though but
it's stupid it's only Knock You Can Have
I know on John's right so it says fun
fact Jon Jones has been arrested more
times than could be uh defended his
heavyweight title you tell me who's the
real goat yeah yeah but uh so here's
this will be the last one so this is
khabib's Dad predicting that Jon Jones
it will be the number one or the top
heavyweight but I'll you know I'll just
play for you real quick
and this is from a while ago 2016. yeah
or something like that oh yeah just
2016.
Gregson
Greg Jackson
John Johnson
um
so you're saying he was gifted from God
not Greg Jackson Greg Jackson was good
as teaching him striking a lot of stuff
but then Jon Jones will be like reigning
topics I'm assuming he's saying instead
for two guys 2016. a prime clean
Velasquez with Johnny beating him that
for sure without a doubt so it came
about came to me when he's healthy best
of all time best ever do it yeah yes
it's only two people he couldn't beat so
one would be Kane and I'm not sure
oh [__]
he didn't say UFC right so
I don't know yeah maybe
but that was a long time ago that was
pretty cool yeah I'm with him though
yeah and that's it for that kind of
solves the goat debate right when your
own dad's like he's the best man
exactly speaking on Jon Jones you got a
fun card this weekend though
uh on four well not unfortunately but
I'll be watching The Green Room in
Oklahoma OKC what up this is the OKC
forget the name of their team that's the
feeder team though to the uh Dodgers
this Oklahoma City Gear right here I'm
in Oklahoma City this Thursday Friday
Saturday OKC bricks Town Comedy Club
come get you some Oklahoma City uh one
show Thursday one show or two shows
Friday two shows Saturday that's March
9th the 11th then Tacoma Washington is
March 23rd through the 25th get your
tickets at thickboy.com or fatkz.com uh
so I'll be watching the fight night in
The Green Room in Oklahoma City on
Saturday night because you have a great
card you know UFC Fight Night Peter yawn
versus uh freaking
uh you got volkov versus ramanov that's
fun
we're called Ramos Austin linga said
[__] Murdoch is gonna crush it he's an
absolute monster with my favorites to
watch he's probably my favorite fighter
on that card
um yeah solid card
lipsky's fighting She's Always a badass
easy on the eyes
who else you got fighting abubakar who
is uh khabib's cousin yep khabib's
cousin
but sets relate to him too right no so
Seth has the same last name but not
related yeah so it's a problem however
for Bellator which I think is Friday
I believe this is Friday March 10 right
yeah that's right so Benson Henderson
he's gonna fight uh I think for the
title
Usman
khabib's cousins he has two cousins
fighting this weekend yeah
you're standing is doing the damn thing
this weekend yeah yeah and then Michael
page yep he's fighting
tough fight that's a fun fight
and
doing the damn thing enjoy the fights
then fellas enjoy the so Friday night
that's in San Jose too Friday night you
got an Omega met off versus Benson
Henderson Bellator Saturday you got a
great Main Event so enjoy the fights
Oklahoma City I will see this weekend
Thursday Friday Saturday Bricktown
Comedy Club get you some thickboy.com
that's it kids hope you enjoyed the
fights if you haven't watched the
combats fight campaign with Will Compton
from busting with the boys and Barstool
and Rampage Jackson it's one of my
favorites of all time I was laughing so
damn hard I could barely get the reads
out uh go watch right now it's on thick
boy YouTube alright thanks for tuning in
thanks for watching like and subscribing
love you guys till next time if you're
into thick boys
like subscribe comment
and God bless America well that's not my
big one just kidding